männertrip reagiert denn wir wollten
wirklich wissen heute fachleute servus
expert willkommen zu einem neuen video
entwertet auf ok ich hab' momentan in
der uni einiges zu tun ich habe zu viel
stress wird vier präsentation auf einmal
und was soll ich sagen gleichzeitig bin
ich auf youtube ziemlich unter beschuss
verkehr und sympathisch machten video
mich wie das mädchen damals und die
disney letzte auch einfach es ist viel
auf einmal wirklich viel und ihr aber es
würde ich sagen leute wenn man schon am
boden ist weniger angestrengt ist
unrichtig wertpapier kann dann kommen
die leute selbst ständig dreht noch mal
richtig einen drauf und zeigen einfach
mal richtig dass man so der letzte arsch
und warum sollte ich jetzt heute alles
und warum heißt dieses video auch ansage
an es kay fragt ihr euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich gerade es gibt ganz
einfachen grund leute ich kann schon
wieder der anlage nicht auf mehr und
geforscht leute ich mit guten vorsätzen
unter beschützt und ich komme gar nicht
ein bisschen an sagen hinterher das
letzte ansagen die bilan er drei wochen
oder so es gibt zunächst zwar ist dieses
video einfach ansage an sks haufen im ok
und die beschreibung des videos sagt
schon alles ansager netscape den pfad
mit zahnpasta und ich habe einen haufen
hühnersuppe es kay hat nicht mal drei
augen und sie lernten lacht weise
beteiligt
die beschreibung hat mich schon total
gegeben und wenn man hier gute bewertung
des videos anschaut 0/58 leute weil habt
ihr zum letzten mal ein youtube-video
mit 0 likes gesehen das habe ich noch
nie gesehen
trotzdem gibt aber auch die ansage und
was macht man als ehrenmann
dann muss ich natürlich dass anlage
video anschauen und darauf reagieren
[Musik]
ok erst mal der erste eindruck von dem
video menschen abstoßend gut gefüllt auf
jeden fall das ist 2017 noch leute gibt
die videos hochkant hochladen ich
versteh's nicht hören in seinem leben
ein youtube video geschaut hat dann weiß
man dass ein youtube-video so aus die
türkei das video als bereiter ist es
hoch her
warum wird man hochkant die vorquartale
ok wollte ich wissen heute dass ich
zurück schiebt ein lappen hingelegt und
gesagt wird es ähnlich wie erkenne ich
damit sagen ich weiß dass ich damit
sagen ich bin auch lassen eher klein
ihr seid in der goldesel fans sind das
vielleicht von goldesel bezahlte spitze
hat goldesel da seine finger die
spielleute beauftragten anlage gegen
mich zu machen damit ich aufgebe damit
ich meinen kanal dickmacher und
vielleicht oder mein gold ist ihr
unternehmen
[Musik]
die punkte heute bin langsam wir
gewinnen merkel aber jetzt schon immer
zu verbannen
ohne witz irgendwem von euch schreibt
mir die adresse von den leuten in den
kommentaren und dann gehe ich bei denen
vorbei und ein bisserl werde ich dir mal
richtig zeigen dass man so was machen
kann wird auf jeden fall wird ihm mit
der mutter von den beiden jungs reden
und welche mal richtig ordentlich sagen
dass das nicht gut finden dass mich das
sehr getroffen hat wir müssen mal wieder
forstleute die sag ich mal gerne
vergisst weil sowas
es gab leute irgendwo in deutschland
vermutet dass im deutschen keine
schweizer keine österreicher die sich
gedacht haben eine gute idee wer weiß
was sie setzten zwar hin und führen
einen schmutzigen waschlappen mit
herzchen drauf und nennen das video
ansage an sp und verstellt und so
stimmen noch so dafür klingen als wenn
wir dreimal als kinder gegen die wand
geworfen worden
jeder normale mensch wird ansagen
bescheuert aber nicht die leute die
haben natürlich gesagt jawoll die gute
idee ihr wollt also wirklich wissen will
ich auf das video reagiere dann gibt es
stress bis dir was leute das ist okay
jetzt geht's los das ist bis jetzt ist
kein sprachen gehe ich von euch weiter
heraus wie auch immer ihr seid kommt
nicht bei mir vorbei ok auch sonst tut
einfach aber wir treffen uns kleine team
und socken jump league eins gegen eins
wie echte männer okay wenn ihr euch
traut den mut habt dann kommentiert
unter diesem video und sagt für die
herausforderung annehmen weil wenn die
herausforderung mich annimmt
jetzt hat bedeutet dann hat die stiftung
hat ihr schiff die echte männer damals
in minecraft zu messen und leute das
heutige benachrichtigungs showdown geht
raus einen punkt fakten der gute die
gute nachricht zum einen kanal angemacht
vielen dank dafür ja auch ins heute
haben wollte einem video müsst ihr
einfach liebe nachrichtenkanal amazon
heißt auf die glocke klicken und
benachteiligung für aktivieren und dann
unter dem video kommentieren dass er die
glocke an gemacht hat oder ich bin nach
yuan gemacht hat dann nimmt automatisch
an der verlosung teil und bekommt
vielleicht im nächsten video auf den
sport aus dank bist du schon so weit die
umkleidekabinen zufällig altes video
abchecken heusweiler slowaken